this surprises me
uh
i
you know i didn't think it'd be this big
of a deal obviously getting sucker
punched breaking your tooth and i guess
he messed up his 90 000 rolex i know
rolex is that has to be some sort of
weird rolex it can't be like a daytona i
don't think he's into like vintage
rolexes some vintage ones go well over
you know 60 70k 90k rolex it would have
to be some like diamond type of
encrusted rolex so that's weird to me
but he was saying the the rolex is
messed up too yeah fifteen thousand
dollars worth of damage so you must have
scraped his rolex
um
yeah
um
you know i i i was i was surprised he's
pressing charges just from
you know fired at a fighter things
happen um and especially since remember
they go back man they were roommates
best friends press charges especially
with you know aggravated assault felony
criminal mischief
pre you know premeditated
felony criminal mischief a great battery
you know if you press charges and he's
found guilty which he will be he's
looking at time dude do you really want
to put moswell away for i don't know two
years three years over this
seems a little excessive i i wish
you know someone could get uh
kobe's there and just like don't press
charges dude then don't do that man
but also for mozville again same [ __ ]
you can't be hitting people dude
especially in the sucker punch part
that's the psychopunch part's weird but
also he won mma fighting before i was
like yo i'm known for sucker punching
and this that which is so sweet and
dining and dash or something like that
yeah it's it's so straight
you know that's not very gangster man
whatever you think is gangster that
would be the opposite where i come from
right yes and he's from like
you know miami
they're pretty rough in the streets
there nobody respects the guy who's
sucker punching people never another
thing was mazda and i like muslim man so
i hate doing this
the thing is
bro you got paid for 25 minutes
to literally do whatever you want to him
besides the legal down knees or you know
12 to 6 elbows outside that whatever you
want to do daddy you had 25 minutes you
got paid for it on
pay-per-view worldwide tv you got your
ass whipped
so i could see
you know if there's like an eye poke or
something like kobe cheated or something
like that and kobe be beat his ass for
25 minutes dude
and then you retaliate by
finding out what restaurants he had and
sucker punching them
i would respect it more if it's like
mazda all
knew kobe's at this restaurant was
pissed i was talking about his kids
which bet asprin did and people have
done before so and then you square up
with them like you approach a man to man
you know i'm like what are you doing are
you fighting the street
all right good still a little dicey but
you know and also you're making legit
money now moswell's never been bigger
even coming off a loss never been bigger
dude he's huge
you know you like had two to three years
in prison probably dude
it's so stupid and for what
you see did it feel good to suck punch
guy and clip his tooth when you got
literally destroyed for 25 minutes
legally by commission
in the sport
to make sense
then i you know i don't see social media
so i'm sure people are like oh my is it
all badass this is where it counts
you know how stupid of a take that is
it doesn't count anybody can sucker
punch anybody
i could walk up behind france's gonna
right now and sucker punch him who gives
a [ __ ] that is the most [ __ ] [ __ ] in
the world man nobody respects that if
you do my god man what are you doing
with your life if you respect the sucker
punch you're a sucker yourself man that
ain't the way to go about life man it's
just such [ __ ] [ __ ]
i just i don't get that why anybody in
the world respect any of this from will
smith to mosbidol
to will smith basically a cheap shot too
yeah
it's just [ __ ]
tendencies dude soft [ __ ] society's
getting softer and softer
anybody who's sticking up for will smith
or stake out from mozball it's just soft
betta soy soyboy [ __ ] dude just soft man
i don't understand it
and mazel has been around too long and
finally dude you're making money you get
your fight league your tequila you're on
every billboard in miami everybody loves
you i love you and you do something like
this dude
and to the point of being a dad you got
kids what message i send to your kids
it's so stupid there was no upside to
this
what's the upside mazvidal
just you sucker punched a guy when he
wasn't looking a guy who beat your ass
for 25 minutes just a few weeks ago
so fast forward 10 years from now the
kids are older they go dad how'd that
fight with chloe kevin go there's some
bad blood there weren't you guys like
roommates and trademarks yeah yeah yeah
what happened
you know for five rounds i might have
won one but i got pretty beat up but you
know what i found out he's at a
restaurant and i walked up behind him
and sucker punched him kids are like
oh
that cool i guess and what happened
there i served five years that's why i
wasn't around
it's insane
nobody respects the guy who stuck a
bunch of people nobody respects the
bigger man who slaps a small comic it's
just all beta soy boy [ __ ]
i can't vouch for it man i don't ride
with it
all right so this writer
for mania he brought up something that
mazel can use for his defense
potentially it's the mutual combat rule
and the reason why he's saying that is
because there was an interview
um in 2020 with mike heck emily fighting
and then this is what colby covington
said
kobe looked ridiculous
100
me
and street judaism are 100 percent gonna
fight before it's all said and done we
we might fight a couple times because if
i see him in the street it's gonna be a
fade session he's gonna get put on the
concrete i'm gonna drop him on his
[ __ ] head and put stitches in the
back of his head
it's not going to be nice mike i promise
you that and he knows that deep down
inside he knows but he's willing to take
a paycheck in the ufc to get his ass
well because he knows the ufc is going
to pay his [ __ ] medical bills
but besides that if he if if we find the
street i'm going to drop him on his
[ __ ] head and he's never gonna be the
same person again because he's gonna be
concussed the concrete's gonna mess with
him
and i'll probably kick his teeth in too
while i'm at it
just because he's a piece of [ __ ] i mean
i mean the guy's claiming i mean he's
the sucker punch king you know he's
claiming for being out at denny's and
being the dinan dash king dude
you're a piece of [ __ ] man you're dining
and dashing and single mothers that are
working at denny's because you know
they're trying to put food on the table
for their child and you're you're
bragging about being proud of dining and
dashing on them
dude the guy is the lowest scum
denominator of earth and he's the fakest
piece of [ __ ] he turned his back on me
for money and his management team
and people are going to find out the
real truth about him i mean he's going
to get exposed soon i know so much about
him and and it doesn't make sense to
come out again
it'll all be built up i think too but
that's a weird defense because i mean
that's like the only thing you could do
yeah it's gonna be tough in the court of
law too because
you know he's talking about a street
fight yeah and i can sucker punch
exactly because it wasn't a fight so
technically
um i'm sure the defense team's gonna eat
that up like yeah he's talking about a
fight fight they screw off in a fight
fight also
um
if we're going to go off of
what kobe kevin says or any fighter for
that matter
you know it's like how many fighters
have you heard say what sean strickland
say i want to kill a guy in the ring or
some [ __ ] like that so it's like
they're selling they're they're they're
entertainers colby more so than anybody
talks so much [ __ ] to get you to hate
him so you tune in to see if he loses he
just happens to be one of the best
welterweights on the planet he's tough
to [ __ ] beat unless your name's
camaro hoosman or hamzad for that matter
but um
so it's gonna be a tough tough leg to
stand on man you know he talked so much
[ __ ] yeah and also but that and also the
mutual combat legal uh in florida
so in florida mutual combat is
recognized defense because both parties
consent to being touched
as an unsure conscious of a altercation
both parties must be at fault and the
defendant must not be primary aggressor
initiate the fight what she did which
is then she just doesn't get a hold of
any facet yeah
hey man i just really hope colby drops
the charges like i hope they settle out
of court might as well i was like yo
i'll get your new rolex just don't make
me surprised i got kids man and i don't
see myself get a [ __ ] prisoner or
something stupid [ __ ] it's a mistake and
you know in the same time but again
kobe talks so much [ __ ] finally you know
it comes back to haunt you a little bit
man but it shouldn't shouldn't be sucker
punched that's the thing i hate yeah if
it was a straight-up fight equal fight
on the street like you're walking this
car in mazel what's up yeah it's all
good you're talking all that stuff about
the street fight here i am
all good you guys figure it out yeah
hopefully no one gets killed but you
know i don't want that but yeah go ahead
and fight there if you want